- Time's almost up on this hour.
But first, let's share one
last story I'm obsessed with.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
All of us can only hope
that we can continue to follow
our dreams in retirement.
A former Montana school
teacher's doing just that
in the most incredible way.
She turned a van into a mobile bookstore
and she road trips across the country
sharing her love of reading with strangers
and making endless
friends along her journey.
We have her on the line right now,
dialed in from her traveling bookstore,
parked in Eureka, Montana.
Everybody say hello to
Rita watching on KXLY 4.
(audience cheering)
Hi Rita.
Hello, so this is really unique.
So, what made you wanna do this?
- Well, I live in a really
small town in Montana,
1500 people, and I realized if
I wanted to open a bookstore
that it couldn't be a
brick and mortar bookstore
or I'd go broke.
So, brainstormed and came up with the idea
of a traveling bookstore.
I can take it where
there's people, festivals,
farmers markets, cities, and
set up and I have customers.
And when I'm not on the road
then it just stays parked in my driveway.
So I've been doing it for
about eight years now,
and I've traveled all across the country.
I've been to the east coast three times,
down the west coast a bunch of times.
Just came back from a
trip in the mountains
and Great Plains.
So it's, yeah, it's a
wonderful experience.
I carry about six to 700 volumes
of books in the bookstore
and then I have some storage in the back
for extra books for when I'm on the road
for a long period of time.
- You've gotta figure it out.
That's rent free.
That's awesome.
That is, you've gotta figure it out.
I would love, I love bookstores
and I love like small
boutique kind of things too
'cause you never know
what you'll find in them.
So, I would adore this if I ran into you.
I'm going to find you.
But you say this isn't about
making money though, right?
- Right.
I do make enough money to cover gas
and tires and insurance and fees,
things like that when I am on the road.
So I say that the
bookstore pays for itself
and I pay for myself.
So, that's the way it works.
For the kids, I really feel
like books should be affordable.
So I make all the kids books $1
whether they're picture books or.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- Chapter books.
And that way kids can afford it.
If they come to a farmer's market
and they wanna buy other
things, they can afford a book.
- That's so cool.
My kids would adore it as well.
Thank you so much, Rita.
This is really cool what you're doing.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, Makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- [Rita] Thank you so much.
- No, thank you so much, Rita.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
George and Mayan Lopez, Allison Sweeney,
Maddy, Zach, and Jake Miller.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.